seven years ago in 2012 Mohamed Morsi
became Egypt's first
democratically-elected president a
member of the Muslim Brotherhood which
has since been outlawed Morsi won 51
percent of the vote his election
followed the Arab Spring uprising which
saw the end of a 30-year rule under
previous president Hosni Mubarak Morsi
promised to head a government for all
Egyptians but dissatisfaction quickly
grew prompting huge protests against him
many were angry about the Muslim
Brotherhood's influence on politics and
believed Morsi had failed to deliver on
his promises after just one year in
office Morsi was ousted in a military
takeover led by Egypt's current
president Abdel Fattah al-sisi Morsi was
immediately arrested and remained behind
bars until his death he was serving a
life sentence related to the killing of
protesters in 2012 demonstrations and he
was facing at least six other trials his
supporters say the charges against him
were politically motivated and that he
was being mistreated and denied medical
treatment whilst in prison the Muslim
Brotherhood has blamed the Egyptian
government for his death turkish
President Recep Tayyip aired one paid
tribute to Morsi while also condemning
President al-sisi Halle rest our brother
Morsy our martyrs soul and peace no the
tyrant Sisi who took power in Egypt by
suppressing democracy through coup so
far executed nearly 50 Egyptians and the
West has remained silent
meanwhile Egypt's chief prosecutor has
released a statement saying medical
experts will determine the cause of
morsi's death seemingly so sudden in the
courtroom on Monday
okay with so many questions out there
let's go straight to Cairo and
journalist Ruth Michelson good morning
Ruth thanks for joining us
Amnesty International is among those
calling for an investigation into
morsi's death what more do we know well
as you mentioned Amnesty International
are calling for an investigation
they say that because former President
Morsi was held for solitary confinement
in almost almost six years that that
breaches the standards of torture under
international law and that they say the
Egyptian government is required to
investigate the reasons why former
president Morsi died there was also a
group of British MPs who formed
something called the detention review
panel which investigated the conditions
under which the new president Morsi was
being kept and they said that the lack
of medical care and inadequate medical
care for his liver disease and diabetes
meant that he was a risk of premature
death which they declared in a report
last year and so you know there are many
groups that drew a long-term attention
to the conditions under which he was
being held okay so a lot of questions
out there a lot of allegations what's
the Egyptian government saying about
them and about how he died well as you
mentioned at each public prosecutor said
in a report that they would investigate
they also said that shortly before 5
p.m.
Cairo time yesterday former president
Morsi was dead on arrival at a hospital
in Cairo and that he had died after
fainting and collapsing in the courtroom
they said that they seized the cameras
that were in the courtroom and that they
questioned those who were inside the
defendants cage with him which implies
that they are under scrutiny and they
also reportedly buried in an unknown
site to the east of Cairo early this
morning in an effort to prevent his
Braves from becoming a pilgrimage site
for his supporters ok now the the Muslim
Brotherhood that Morsi once led is
calling for protests so what can we
expect in Cairo in the days
well there is likely to be some outrage
it is you know important to remember
that this man was an extremely
controversial figure he was a symbol of
democracy and freedom for some a group
that was long underground and then came
to rule Egypt but for others he and seen
as an enemy of the state and was seen as
this right up until the time of his
death even though he was in prison
it's also important to remember the
context that mass protests especially by
the Muslim Brotherhood who are
considered a terrorist organization in
Egypt that these mass protests have been
essentially banned since the law in 2013
so while there's likely to be some anger
among most his supporters it's also
unlikely that we would see a mass
democratic event like we saw in 2011 or
2012 Ruth Michaelson and Cairo for us
thanks very much